oh my god oh my god it's the Jason
Bourne movie reviews Gregory is my real
name jon is my name poor David Webb we
saw Jason Bourne John saw this movie
twice hey John yeah I want you to know
staring my legs are your legs you guys
can't see this your legs are like spread
out like this my legs are like crunch
this is your audition so like we just
sit back a little oh look solution
implement it now but your watch wider
than I'm like not I'm not like listen
azari to knocked over your huh look you
know it's funny we saw this movie
together as a second time he was
watching I didn't know that John likes
that was weird secret sparrow thank you
for watching because people get weird
when you tell them you've seen a movie
already when I was watching this movie I
just come off of finishing ultimatum
like a couple days prior to watching it
the bourne trilogy was fresh in my head
to this day still haven't seen legacy I
want to watch it I don't have like I
hate towards it I just didn't see it as
being vital to watching this movie you
like most people are like his not jason
boy what are we doing this when this
movie first finished I was a little let
down by it I told John lie god this
daughter was alright it very much felt
like born on repeat if you watch our
honest trailer video that we did
reacting and discussing the bourne
trilogy we go over the bourne formula i
realize it's in all these films
including this latest one and yeah it's
all there like all the bourne formula is
there horn has one kind of situation
play out in his life and it's this one
and and the thing that I guess keeps it
fresh every time is that the tech is
always updated and then yeah of
real-world circumstances are always more
modern true so but yeah it is always
kinda the same few when this movie
starts off it shows that born has been
off the grid for nine years now and he
fights because he man I know he needs
money and he's you know like relives his
trauma I likes to let himself get hurt
or he like it's some type of physical
pain thing associated with violence and
killing
all that in this she's dramatic pass
there's a little bit of that like I can
never let myself get soft and not that I
didn't want born to you know be all
happy and [ __ ] after all this time he
tried that all right Felicia at work
yeah ultimatum ended it like they and
I'm okay to say that because green grass
and Damon said we're not gonna do
another one to portal two main event in
it there's no [ __ ] point doing
another one we can't tell another story
I heard it interviews and there's even
we saw some are colliding even at the
end of arc light the mat deeper sad
thing they say yeah is like what's wrong
with other tape yeah little fan service
is just fine if you can latch onto that
this will help manage your expectations
because it is fan service and it is not
entirely necessary you see with the dog
it seems it feels born cliche not they
didn't feel like van service because I
didn't feel like Paul Greengrass was
setting out to make a movie that was
like really entertaining fan service of
the bourne movie it felt like he's
trying to make another really serious
moving action picture well it seems like
he wants to tell another born story
because you don't want to get if people
want another born they gave him another
born approach not like a we're gonna
make it just cool like yeah fine i still
can't quite pinpoint what is all those
with eats is fanservice it hits those
beats but it's done in the same paul
greengrass serious tone that it feels
kind of orange stereotypical as opposed
to like oh I get what we're doing we're
having the fan service aboard you gotta
get what i mean by yeah yeah because
there's not a treatment of fun flavor to
it it is still very serious it's very
it's like still really serious like it's
thrilling but it is like not many of you
know it crack a smile no no one smiles
and born is like even more you know
personnel are ever ready and i'll kind
of upset than usual which makes sense
but I was kind of let down by seeing
that born hasn't really moved on at all
he's like the same exact guy that he was
in supremacy and it also Clues you into
like i hearing you say nine years makes
you think about it different cuz it's
like it's easy to lose track of the time
and not realize just how long he's been
in hiding and for like almost ten years
like that's enough time that you could
down and start a life and he's still
just yeah cuz [ __ ] dudes his
ultimatum ends in a way where he got all
the answers shred stones been exposed
and it's and like people can't find his
body so he's been able to go into hiding
so I feel like okay now this is yeah
it's his closure time so I would have
liked to have seen born like picking up
on it so living like what guy for it to
pick up at a point where born has not
moved on and that he still needs more
answers or something but then they go
into the mission which is like this is
just retraining born formula to me with
granted there's still some great action
sequences the riot chasing that you see
on the trailers worries on the
motorcycle really well-executed yeah
it's it's perfectly edited a choreograph
it is really well storyboarded okay I
think I think I figured out as I was
talking about it cuz even um Matt Damon
and Paul Greengrass we're saying yeah we
just wanted you know entertaining that
they said they the finales that Las
Vegas you know action sequence that they
wanted to build a movie around I don't
feel like any of the other Bourne movies
did something like that it felt like
they had a story first and that's why
the fight scenes were so epic too
because it was so [ __ ] emotionally
intense in a subtle way at the same time
like my ultimatum was so intense the
stakes feel different in the urgency
feels different in the first three then
this one does I didn't give you that
born is really on his own in this movie
too there's no one really that he
interacts with Bourne Identity he had
his Maria Maria and some aegina
supremacy you see him with Maria so you
see this personal loss that he has
written barks on this mission alone with
any interacts with Nikki and Pamela
Landy and a third one he has nikki and
this one like he's alone for most of it
ezel unfertile has no one to talk to all
you really get is born on a mission yeah
that's true his he is oddly like the the
kind of thing that's keeping the plot
moving but he's not most of the movie
yet things like you you probably tallied
up the time I remember thinking on the
first half hour like there's a lot of
other characters in this which is cool
to see that they brought a lot of new
characters and well and I kind of keep
forgetting that born is of the integral
part cuz I yeah I felt like without
going into spoilers i felt like born
truly wasn't necessary to the bigger
picture until the finale and I felt like
that was sort of
I chance that he became more necessary
at least in terms of like the
interactions and the emotional stakes
cuz the plot of the movie is all around
him but it's easy to kind of forget that
because his motivations pretty clear on
it gets a you know the next head guy I
do give you that but I think that's also
a thing that played positively for me
about this movie because almost in the
same way like Mad Max is in a situation
but we also get to learn about all these
other people and their urgency drives
this day ahead you know for movies and
I'm like I think that's actually kind of
cool and i liked the the other
characters that we focus why i thought
tommy lee jones is great and i liked
alicia vikander to Tommy Lee Jones is
really really good it's come glad to see
Tommy Lee Jones like in a big movie
again giving a great dramatic yes he's
on his a game like he's mommy Lee Jones
but like in the best way because light
is aching yeah you know these directors
are always a little bit like you know
[ __ ] up and corrupt in some way cuz
they're trying to cover up their past as
well but Tommy Lee Jones you see that
he's a lot more ruthless than the other
one yeah like even more than Brian Cox
was and supremacy I feel like Tommy Lee
Jones like he had like there's this
great hey I can't give it away but there
is it there is that great sequence where
he's like talking to several people on
his phone and he's just in his office
yeah and he's like manipulating this
whole situation and you're just like man
Tommy Lee Jones is a real [ __ ] yeah
he will like her your feelings if it
means getting what he wants oh yeah it's
rushing killing anyone who doesn't
matter and he sell he does a really good
job of selling it the first time but
especially the second time is you're
watching these characters play like
tactical chess and lay out his action
like that stuff keeps it thrilling
despite not having a ton of Jason Bourne
development for me I sort of felt like
this story got a little bit caught up
now that the phone was uneven I just
felt like he didn't know where to give
most of its emotional focused towards
was either born or this other story
about privacy yeah yeah in the internet
world which is a cool store that's what
I mean it's like it still has the pacing
and the kind of scenes in the right
order it's just who we're focusing on
keeps ya feeling a little like 0
interest because you get this character
who's like they're working with you get
this other character who's like the
Silicon Valley kind of guy
yeah he's great in the movie he's a
really good character it feels like it's
the same movie but a separate story it's
just updated for the for the era of the
Snowden leaks and of yeah major hacking
in social media and again like that's
the thing I think is cool it's like if
you don't update the formula you've
least updated the things in the world
you're using that's sort of like ripped
from the headlines quality and I thought
that was a really good subplot like
anything the thing is like they built to
movie around this Vegas chase and like
to build a movie around to chase they
really reverse engineered it pretty well
and me because I like that whole tech
angle that gets us and then and the
chase is really cool it's a it's a great
chasing and that's the thing is like
even if you see bourne-style action
scenes in this movie like you know the
the riot chase scene and there's the
Vegas chase scene and some of the
fistfights they're top notch and like
you feel it manly ya feel the force like
they remind you that even though these
cuttin these chases are getting
convoluted and these people would
probably be dead this is probably the
biggest difference of just stunts and
[ __ ] they put you right there and in
their shot and assembled so well that
they do feel yeah it's like it hits the
bourne notes it's weird because it's not
a bad movie by any means it just felt a
little bit opposite in terms of instead
of structure and a story and including
action sequences it felt like they had
action sequences and they built a story
around that you still get some great
stuff and they're like okay the asset is
a cliche born formula thing but vincent
cassell I thought he was a great
addition to it because yeah yeah it's a
fun fact he was the villain in Ocean's
Twelve placing really remember it's been
so the guy who sets up they like reading
them all out to andy garcia and he likes
sets up the plan for them to steal that
egg being the vase or whatever in the
museum oh man ye that flips to the
lasers and stuff does that impossible
like that's right yeah yeah Ocean's
eleven is one mad Dame and 13 is when
Matt Damon was in Vegas dude it's all
part of the same year who's the same guy
this is what he was doing suppose those
nine minutes before treads
exactly okay like the whole story that
they have here is born starting to learn
so there's a new there's a new
Treadstone which is what again which is
what ultimatum was they're always gonna
do I hire elite contract killers like on
so there's there's a new Treadstone born
you know what's the fun of information
but he also finds out his father was
probably involved in Treadstone in a
much bigger way than he realized so he
wants to find out answers to that you
see that's my thing though with the film
that could have been a very like
powerhouse finding out shikon a moment
and added the emotional intensity to the
movie however there's a much bigger
thing at hand that I actually kind of
found more interesting than born story
going on yeah the thing is I found that
so interesting that it made me enjoy the
movie but there is Lauren starts to
learn about his dad and and that's kind
of just what he's learning about is
there's not it doesn't really blossom
much beyond that because the other part
of the plot is going on doesn't really
involve him exactly that's that's why I
meant been born doesn't feel that
necessary and then by chance there's an
incident that happens that was like oh
now born is the center of attention
these are really like two situations
that Tommy Lee Jones and Alicia vikander
are both involved in it's just one of
them yeah exactly like that for this
movie it's not Jason Bourne involved in
situations so it kind of felt like they
were running out of steam of telling
stories about Jason Bourne when I kind
of feel like you don't you know what I
think the thing would have been cool
like my own little born fan fiction
movie is if they just did a story about
Vincent cuz Vincent Cassell's the asset
the assets usually just the asset that's
it he's hired to kill born and then he
has a fight scene that's really awesome
a born eventually um which but but the
asset here they made it a very personal
vendetta that he has with born with very
good reasoning as to why he has hatred
towards born yeah instead of just a guy
who Jason Bourne recognizes as you know
one of his own like this guy actually
has something with I think a cool movie
would be like it that asset going after
him while he's off the grid oh and you
know like he's been hiding away but now
they're coming after him it says one guy
with a personal mission it's not about
Treadstone or every yeah it's about like
I want my revenge against you born like
that would have been it cool like oh and
do that do the whole like government
black
cop psychology yeah watching a two
different sides of the bed whatever cool
and Julia Stiles is back for a look and
I I'm pretty obvious what was gonna
happen her like those right away it was
very variable I was worried and touches
they added to her I thought were kind of
cool like okay she's went off the grid
to and she's like worked off more lethal
but something about her like she's
having this like exchange of dialogue
with born in the streets I'm like you
sound like oh and emotionally yeah
there's something up with her delivery
that just seemed like really bland I
couldn't tell if it was just like a bad
ATR yeah cuz she's been better she's
like she's better in the other movie
yeah it didn't seem like a lazy thing
you just seemed like there was a lack of
choice here that in terms of performance
I don't know that's like if you're into
the Bourne film like this what I will
say is this film has been growing on me
the more I think about it like if i
watch the bourne movies again i would
totally put this on I wouldn't be like
not that one doesn't count yeah i would
put i would totally put it on there's
some great stuff in it to the action
sequences are great it there's just a
lack of interest for me that i felt the
lack of being captivated and truly
pulled in like on the edge of my seat
ultimatum man like and supremacy there
are moments in that where I'm just like
like this is so intense I need to tell
someone that this isn't it you know well
actually that's the thing is like like
like full disclosure the last time I
watched you know the bourne trilogy was
a little while ago and I decided you
know not to go redo the marathon cuz i
wanted to go and fresh and i'd heard all
the reviews and stuff so my expectations
were pretty middling and i walked out
really having enjoyed it and the second
time I thought I was gonna find a lot
more flaws and I really enjoyed it again
so I feel like if you haven't watched
them all in a while you'll enjoy it more
because you're not gonna have like the
really succinct quality of the first
three hanging above you which is but
that's that's kind of like we're the
downfall of the experience comes in so
because you need to watch those movies
so yeah like this movie that's a fun
yeah if you come off of these movies
immediately you might not like it as
much it yeah totally because the first
three that it's a succinct trilogy in it
and it has it says they intended it
and then this feels again as fanservice
and as a continuation we didn't need
everyone I thought really brought their
a-game and made it so much more like
they put much more effort into it and I
enjoyed it so much more than I could
have been they could have yeah as far as
the typical summer blockbuster goes this
is a [ __ ] up short way more work at
birth we're just giving fans something
cool that they want this is like wow you
really did a good job like you really
invested in this I feel like people
forget that the Bourne Identity part one
is a lot of fun supremacy and ultimatum
our way darker they're green Paul
Greengrass you know yeah I feel like
Paul Greengrass doesn't know how to just
make a really fun movie when I feel like
that's what he they kind of wanted to do
with this was make a fun movie that some
of they keep telling people like we just
want to make an entertaining film and
while it has entertainment it lacks a
sense of fun yeah it is pretty it's grim
especially like a really great red
ribbon and when you get later on in the
movie like there is some of those fight
scenes where I'm like this is so brutal
like this and this is an orbit like this
yeah dark violence well um yeah if I
have to get this rating i would say uh
you know good time no alcohol required
yeah it's a good time it's a six and a
half seven schmoes I think the amount of
five jennife dead three and
three-quarter hundred out of a thousand
schmoes gets Duckman gets people
subscribe to the real rejecter we have
our tag lines too yeah reasons to Jerry
yeah dank ass Bob sub and facebook.com
slash blue house and the real rejects
this guy's a lot of social media [ __ ]
going on shout out to aaron cross aaron
one day people will recognition no
that's gonna it's gonna be like
halloween three years and they are or
blair witch to wear like 15 years later
people like hey that's it it's actually
pretty good yeah i think it's getting
there is it I think it's getting there
maybe this movie will be the one where
people go like even the last movie news
but we should watch last but because
when legacy remap people were like
surprisingly not bad it's not great it's
not bad